désormais quand il ya une grève en
france personne ne s'en aperçoit 2008
voilà une petite presse qui n'est pas
passée inaperçue elle est signée nicolas
sarkozy alors président de la république
c'est une phrase de trop du président de
la république il est habitué de ce type
de provocation mais au fond nicolas
sarkozy avait t-il raison
disons qu'avant sa déclaration la france
a connu des temps très rythmée par les
grèves des années 60 et en particulier
[Applaudissements]
d'autres mouvements d'ampleur ont
ponctué les années 70 et 80
sans compter la grève massive de 1995
contre la réforme des retraites et la
pagaille qu'elle a causés d'un côté je
suis pour eux de l'autre ça fait chier
dans les années 2000 en revanche la
contestation est devenue plus calme
désormais quand il ya une grève en
france personne ne s'en aperçoit un an
avant cette phrase il faut rappeler que
nicolas sarkozy fraîchement élu a fait
passer une loi peu anodine celle dite du
service minimum
il est adopté en réalité elle n'impose
pas de service minimum mais elle oblige
des salariés à se déclarer grévistes 48
heures à l'avancé
c'est un article qui est là pour faire
peur pour dissuader le salarié qui
voudraient faire grève de faire grève 48
heures à l'avancé le temps de mettre en
place le fameux service minimum
permettant un accès même restreint aux
services publics écoles et roquefort est
pénalisé par la grève c'est quand même
très compliqué notamment dans les
transports
résultat un an après grève de 2009
le rer n'est pas bondée pas de cohue
dans les gares les routes sans même plus
fluide que d'habitude j'ai mis 30
minutes est d'habitude mais une heure et
demie c'est génial c'est que les
français ont aussi pris des dispositions
jours de congés rtt covoiturage
télétravail
alors forcément la grève personne ne
s'en aperçoit
mais n'allons pas trop août 2010 la
réforme des retraites fait bondir la
france neuf mois de défilés
un million de personnes dans la rue en
octobre
pénurie d'essence ce mouvement tout le
monde s'en est aperçu de lille à
marseille
les grèves se voit dans les rues mais
aussi dans les transports surtout quand
les cheminots se mobilisent en masse
l'exemple en 2007 ont crevé et n'allez
pas leur dire que la grève personne ne
s'en aperçoit
[Musique]